now I've got a recommendation for you I
want you to go to the dollar store and I
want you to buy some streamers and some
confetti and red white and blue and once
you put them up in your living room and
I want you to throw yourself a
convention in your living room because
you are the one that's going to fix your
life it won't be the Republicans at the
Republican convention and it won't be
the Democrats at the Democratic
convention now a lot of you are doing
nothing but sitting glued to the
television to watch all of these people
and I'll just tell you I'm getting old
and I've seen a lot and none of those
people have ever sent me any money and
none of those people have ever given me
any business none of those people have
affected my life anything but negatively
by taking my freaking money so I want
you to throw yourself a convention
because you are officially as of today
in charge of your life if you didn't
already know that we're here to remind
you your destiny is in your hands it's
not in the hands of Hillary Clinton or
Donald Trump thank God thank God get
down on your knees and thank God for
that that you live in a country where
you can get up today leave the cave be
an honest man an honest woman make an
honest day's wage kill something in drag
at home you are in charge of whether you
retire a millionaire not any of those
people I'm not mad at any of them I'm
just sick and tired of all of you
thinking some of them are gonna fix your
life they're not gonna fix your life and
you are in charge of your life go buy
some streamers put them up in your
living room and throw yourself a self
convention the party of self has just
started throw yourself a self convention
you are in charge of your life your
destiny has a lot more to do with your
actions than it does those folks on
television and all of those perfectly
painted men and
that are commenting on all of these
unperfect li painted men and women I
mean I'm telling you some of those
people are really pretty people on the
TV men they are pretty and there's even
pretty liberals I mean there's pretty
conservatives they're beautiful people I
don't look like that I don't know about
you I'm just a little bald guy I mean I
don't I don't measure up you couldn't
put enough paint on this barn to make it
shine I mean but buddy I'm telling you
some of those people they change colors
that one one network there so orange I
think they're in palookas they got anza
dadgum much makeup I mean they're
beautiful they are beautiful they're not
gonna fix your life they're not going to
fix your life I we turned it on last
night just like you did drawing like a
moth to a dadgum flame just like you got
to stop and look at a car wreck I mean
you got it you're just drawn to it you
know and that's probably probably done I
just cuz I get the idea that all of the
folks on the stage and on the camera and
behind the cameras are really sure that
this matters more than it does it
matters and it's important but your life
is not going to change have you noticed
so I thought when Bill Clinton got
elected that the world came to an end
I was a long time ago I was a lot
younger and you can tell by looking at
him I mean it is and I some of you
thought when George W got elected you
the world come to me and you notice it
and either one happened nor did either
one of them send me money I have zero
money in my bank account because of
those goobers so quit sitting around
spending all your time discussing Trump
isms and Hilary isms and get your butt
back out there and take control of your
life
let your destiny be in your control and
admitting that really
the first step to your changing
everything some of you do that and you
come on here and you do your debt-free
screams and you've changed your life or
you come on here during the millionaire
themed hour and you know those
millionaires they say for 20 years or 25
years or 15 years and they put money in
their 401k every month and they did that
why while Democrats were in the White
House and Republicans were in the White
House while Democrats were in Congress
and Republicans were in Congress and
they won anyway whether there were
protests in the streets or whether there
was a coup in Turkey they went out and
they did business and they want anyway
the 24-hour news cycle has caused some
of you to take your eye off the ball and
the ball is coming right across home
plate at high speeds
swing it hit it don't wait for someone
else to hit for you there are no pinch
hitters in this life baby you get to do
your own hitting look for it it's coming
see it swing better knock it out so we
know da yeah seriously you are in
control of your destiny I have to say
all this stuff because I got to tell you
I get sucked into the emotion of the
campaign cycle just like you do and and
I get sucked into the whole thing of oh
my goodness look at look at so-and-so
and look at what they said and I am so
tempted to get just right down there in
it and you know what I had just to stop
and remind myself they have never done
anything for me none of them except take
my money
I vote for one of them more than I do
the other because they take less of my
money it's that simple and I'm sick of
it and none of them do anything they all
just stand around with a dead gun finger
in their ear and talk if they work for a
real person we'd fire there but all of
them
we've been going you are the most inept
inefficient bozo on the planet go look
for a job somewhere else they wouldn't
last 10 minutes in this organization six
of my leaders would be in my office
going what did we hire that guy for he's
an idiot he just talks all the time he
does nothing
that's what happened if they ever had a
dadgum real job any other so enough of
that but just to remind you not to get I
cuz I'm reminding myself to don't get
sucked down into this stuff like it
matters more than it does it matters
it's important but the ball is coming
across the plate
you got a swing swing for the fence baby
jack that thing pull pull put it over
the butt over the left field man put it
out there you can do it swing there are
no pitch enters coming out of Washington
DC they don't even know there's a game
out here in the real world they think
the game is there it's up to you take
care of your life so go buy you some
streamers go buy you some confetti and
have a convention of me a self
convention and take control of your own
destiny starting right now ready set go
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind
you